when you say you worked with mick jack
what was the occasion that you were
working with
he did a solo album
um called goddess in the doorway and i i
wrote a song for him called god gave me
everything actually we wrote the song
together i started it and then he did
the lyrics how mind-blowing was that you
know he came to my place in miami at the
time where i was living and we recorded
the track and i produced it did you get
blown out by a guy i mean because mick
jagger is like god i mean i love him
we're we're good friends um we've worked
together but when you're in that moment
and he's in the studio
and you press record
i just sit there and go my god it's it's
it sounds like mick jagger it's [ __ ]
making sure mick jack are just coming
out of mick jagger
and it's pretty incredible and when you
sit and write with him because like
keith richards is normally his writing
partner so here he is doing a solo album
and he calls on you
is is there is there pressure i mean
insane pressure to come up with a great
song for him i mean because you only
want to please the guy right no it's
just fun i mean i just kind of go with
the flow
and see what comes up and then uh is it
that you're that confident in your
musical abilities because you play
almost every instrument i know on your
new album you're playing drums you're
playing you know you're playing with all
the guitars are you so confident in
yourself that hey it's mick jagger but i
know what i can do and and i can get
this thing done
it's i don't you know i just think it's
it's fun i just think of it as fun like
what could i do what could i do for this
guy you know what could i present him
with
and i get into
his mode right and something comes out
and uh
how long does it take you to write with
mick jagger when you have to sit down
and write a song with him i did the song
couple nights before he showed up the
track pla cut the whole track had the
melody
and then when he came i did the vocal
thing
sang him the melody and then he said
okay give me a minute he took a pad and
a pen he went in my little den area
sat for about 45 minutes came back with
the lyrics winning and saying just like
that is amazing to me and and you know
what it tells me too it's important for
an artist like yourself to be around
other singers
because you had no idea that your
process was the same as theirs yes and
you pick up you pick up ways of being a
recording artist from other artists
right yeah it's it's interesting to see
how people work